it doesn't even taste vietnamese you
know
[Laughter]
i knew it hi guys my name is yen i am a
food blogger here in san francisco
california today i'm gonna be trying
three different vietnamese dishes from
three different guys and based on which
one i like the most i'm gonna go on a
date with him and yeah it's just purely
based on his dish i don't know what he
looks like so i hope he looks good so
i'm actually from vietnam i have a badmi
tattoo i know a lot about vietnamese
cuisine i've cooked a lot of vietnamese
dishes so they're gonna have to bring
their a game yo i'm terry hi my name is
ben coy hi i'm johnny oh no man i
spilled my tupperware all over my car
this morning i'm confident you know i've
watched a few season master chef so like
i know what's up
[Music]
i like a lot of fried stuff like i'm a
fatty so like i made bangkok basically
like mini versions of bang sale like the
vietnamese fried crepe thingy except
they like come in little circles right
like finger picking food like you can
just grab one like stuff one in your
face i tried making it in two variations
the first one being circular balls which
bangkot usually comes in the other
variation i also tried making it into
heart shapes adding a little love to it
i messed up the batch though as you can
see from here they're all dried and
shriveled
so
it's it smells good because of the fish
sauce too you put fish sauce in there or
is that cap that is fish sauce it's it's
um
bangkok let's go
let's go cheese
it looks like bangkok because usually
bangkok is like tapioca deep fried
tapioca thing with shrimp on top but it
look it looks a little strange
bruh what is this
what is it terry it's my heart oh it
smells good
that's the batter of the bangkok some
dude really put an effort to make it a
heart shape it's kind of messed up but
bro that was my best heart shape i'm
gonna try it now
mmm
raw food not bad this person have a good
understanding of vietnamese food because
not a lot of people know this dish it's
not mainstream like fur or about me she
called me special wow call me special
the only thing is
it's not crispy and the batter might be
a little bit too heavy so it's a bit
chewy that's my style dude and bangkok
is supposed to be crispy i think it's
good though i think he puts an effort
damn putting in the effort terry this
this dish is not a common dish to make
and it's also not the easiest either you
have to get the batter right and then
you have to have this little tray with
holes in them so he has the stuff i
think or unless he used like how did he
make this how did you make that
the pan dude yeah he doesn't take any
shortcuts it seems unless he bought the
fish sauce did you buy the fish sauce no
i made it i think he's a he's
potentially a good guy who you from
scratch wait you actually made your own
fish sauce yeah
i did not expect to see bangkok here
so i made a dish that's very close to my
hometown called rambap essentially corn
spring rolls it's very specific to the
province i'm from guangai
wow yeah
that's a
that's a pronunciation we got butter
lettuce we got cucumbers we got mint and
then we got some cilantro that is salad
and then the dipping sauce is soy sauce
fermented tofu thai chili peppers and
then lime juice hopefully she doesn't
think this is gentrified food
[Music]
egg rolls okay
did he plate this wow he he did a very
nice job plating it
soy sauce but i do have a question why
is it not fish sauce vietnamese egg
rolls we don't use soy sauce that's a
problem ouch she calls my soy sauce a
problem
what is that face
wait what does that face she's making
corn
why is there corn in my egg roll
it doesn't even taste vietnamese
i knew it you know it's like one of
those frozen egg rolls from the american
store
yo this guy was like this dish is from
my homeland it doesn't taste bad
but it's not vietnamese we don't put
corn in our egg rolls this guy
vietnamese wins more vietnamese and the
two of us combined i'm so confused
we cooked the dishes but she's cooking
you bro i don't think he's a real
vietnamese guy he said it's local to his
hometown what region of vietnam put
corns in the egg roast bro
yeah central vietnamese from guangana
given what i know but you said it's a
region and given that each of these
looks different he did make these
himself so i take back that is from the
frozen section honestly i thought you
were gonna get roasted yeah i thought i
was gonna get roasted like this i don't
know
he's from a mysterious place in vietnam
that i want to visit now i'm more
curious about why he used soy sauce
instead of fish sauce did she notice
that i put yao in there like the
fermented tofu i need to meet this guy
i've never had this dish so where in
vietnam is he from oh my mind is
confused she's like questioning her own
identity now do you like it though i
like it actually i like the more i eat
the more i like it i think the initial
reaction was from oh this is not what
i'm used to yeah she got way nicer at
the end
i'm hoping for a bad me i hope one guy
will bring me up on me because that's my
favorite vietnamese cuisine so i made a
bun me brisket sandwich so it has some
nice juicy brisket here with pickled
vegetables and fresh cilantro on top and
i also made this thai basil chimichurri
that is currently melting on my plate
here
oh and there's limes here and a dipping
sauce for dipping so it's kind of like
fur but like in a bunny
yeah and she has a she has a freaking
tattoo
uh
so stands are high you're gonna like
this one
me mommy
i like their reaction bro okay wow who's
this man oh it smells so good
what's up baby there's a fab on me he
incorporated
ingredients the brisket it's probably
cooking for broth or something first
sniff
what's up
he didn't make this right he bought this
from somewhere i'm restaurant quality
baby this is too good it's almost too
good to be homemade well just too good
to be homemade
but you know
i need more sriracha and poison
i put them in i generally like my food a
little bit more flavorful what i put so
much flavor in it he did have something
okay actually i want to try the the meat
she dissecting it if he did make this
i'm very impressed because the meat is
really tender let's just uh you know put
a little
that's a lot
mmm one more oh wait
um
for dipping this dude's legit for
dipping please do not drink for dipping
am i drinking
don't drink it this is creative yes sir
he didn't just make a traditional bun me
or a balfa he was very creative in
infusing both of those dishes and he
actually tried really hard i think this
dude probably like you know make sure
he's as in school and he's like one of
those overachievers that is always
trying to stand out what is that she
called you a nerd bro that's how funny
i'm a bare minimum student his food is
actually really good so i think he's
he's a good candidate but one thing
about me though so i mentioned earlier
that i love about me but another thing
about me is that even as a vietnamese i
do not like fur
dude yes
the plot
i don't know if it's gonna work out
honestly so he has my favorite dish and
also my least favorite dish what are the
odds of all the bang me's you picked in
the world you chose the one she uh she
hates the most
[Music]
you know what my friends told me pick
the worst one because he's gonna be the
hottest one what the wonder what the
worst one in her opinion is bro they
said pick the ones that put in the least
amount of effort but i think all these
guys put in effort okay so this guy i
think knows his vietnamese like he knows
this dish which is not very common in
america i definitely didn't know that
dish did you know that dish yeah
oh okay and i love this dish like it's
one of my favorite when it's done really
well this one is egg rolls but he said
it's from specifically where you know a
certain region of vietnam which i've
never been to so i'm actually most
curious about this guy like where are
you from and this guy he's just a wild
card he either knows his vietnamese food
really well or he doesn't know
vietnamese food but know how to cook so
he's like google what's the best
vietnamese dishes oh fun but let me
combine the two that's the second one
for sure ah if i have to pick right
here's the straight a students right
here right
it's like an overachiever and i love
overachiever but this guy is like you
know stay true to my route if i really
have to choose i do really like smart
kids who are over achievers so i'm
hoping it's this guy he could have just
bought this whole thing from somewhere
right
i think it's this guy i think i'll pick
this guy let's go
my name is johnny hi johnny my name is
ben coy vincoy i'm terry terry i guess
you're the straight a student right now
you don't look like a straight star no
i'm not i don't know how the street
[Music]
[Music]
you